the man who stole Lady Gaga's dogs and
shot her dog walker will spend the next
couple of decades in prison the Los
Angeles County District Attorney's
Office says nineteen-year-old James
Howard Jackson accepted a plea deal with
a 21-year sentence authorities have said
pop Superstar Lady Gaga was not targeted
specifically but instead Jackson and
four other people drove all over Los
Angeles looking for dogs to seal to
steal in fact they were allegedly
looking for French Bulldogs specifically
because they can sell them for thousands
of dollars the dog walker Ryan Fisher
was robbed and shot by Jackson when
authorities put up a reward for the two
dogs that Jackson took another member of
the alleged conspiracy tried to return
them and collect the reward money the
four other people allegedly involved
have all been charged according to
Rolling Stone Fisher talked about his
trauma Jackson's sentencing ultimately
forgiving him for the attack now Terry
the other four people involved they
haven't accepted a plea deal they
haven't gone to trial does this no
contest from Jackson does have an impact
on their cases
it could but I don't think so on no
contest plea is when the defendant
pleads you know no contest basically
he's saying there's enough evidence here
against me but I'm not going to plead
guilty and I'm not going to plead not
guilty I'm saying it's not a contest so
I'm just going to go straight to
sentencing and essentially I think the
others are going to look at that and
they're going to take their chances I
believe because he's not admitting that
he's guilty and frankly they may or may
not have evidence against the others so
if I'm defending those individuals I
might tell them look they don't have
enough evidence against you maybe they
had more evidence against him you should
take your chances and just go ahead
straight to trial so it doesn't
necessarily mean that the others
involved in this are going to plead also
they could but you know they may decide
to take their chance Brian you agree
with that I mean Jackson taking a plea
does it change the strategy to take a
plea or go to trial for the others so I
disagree Jesse because I think what it
does is it pushes you one way or another
what happens now is Jackson is The
Benchmark whatever he did he got 21
years and a no contest please so if I'm
representing someone who did less than
Jackson and has less of a criminal
record I'm going to the prosecutor and
saying hey if he got 21 years then my
guy should get five or three or whatever
it may be and if I can get that number
my client's definitely taking it but if
they've gotten less evidence against my
guy than they do Jackson and I see that
he takes the plea I might be more
inclined to go to trial and throw him
under the proverbial bus to say hey they
got their pound of Flesh they got the
guy who was guilty my guy just an
accessory after the fact didn't know
what was going on you might be able to
win the case but it does affect I like
when you both disagree because you both
provide great arguments I don't know
what to make at the end of the day he
agrees with me at the end
well I do want to talk about something
else because we recently reported on the
gunman who was charged in the murder of
Migos rapper takeoff well now the
suspect is claiming that law enforcement
has the wrong guy the Houston Police
Department announced the arrest of
33-year-old Patrick Xavier Clark on
Friday that was nearly four weeks after
after the 28 year old artist was gunned
down in a private party following what
law enforcement said was a lucrative
dice game after a bond hearing on Monday
Clark's attorney told reporters that her
client is quote nervous and concerned
over being charged with something that
he believes he's innocent of according
to court records when Clark was arrested
he had an expedited passport and a quote
large amount of cash investigators claim
he had plans to flee the country but
Clark's attorney said he had been
planning to go to Mexico on vacation but
just canceled his trip before over now
to a story of Hope out of Waukesha
Wisconsin one year later a holiday
parade returned to a community that has
suffered such tremendous loss parade
goers were seen holding up tribute signs
and floats bore the parade Waukesha
strong they bore the phrase Waukesha
strong as the city remembered their
fellow neighbors who were killed in the
tragedy you might recall last month
Darrell Brooks Jr was sentenced to life
in prison without parole for plowing his
SUV into waukesha's previous holiday
parade he took the lives of six people
injured dozens of others the city
announced on Facebook that a new Parade
route will be put in place along with
vehicle barriers technology devices like
drones and cameras enhanced public
safety personnel on site and other
security measures